[Music]
hello
um we're going to be talking about how
to create reproducible reports
with r uh my name is brian this is my
partner anna santos
i'll be going over the scenario the um
regulations the restrictions and the
goals we face in this project
anna will be going over the project the
program itself and program features
um just a little background we were we
worked for bwi
and last year around january july we
were tasked with creating our program
that can write engineering reports for
engineers
a bit more background so bwi boston's
webster
is a leader in the science of diagnosing
and treating
heart rhythm disorders specifically
athen
aphid can lead to strokes heart failures
and blood clots
and since we develop a product that
comes in contact with the heart itself
we are heavily regulated by the fda in
the documentation section
specifically our reports we are we have
strict guidelines
to how our reports are composed and
presented to the fda bwi itself which
generates about over a thousand reports
a year each report
takes about four work days so that's
total 30 hours
so just doing quick math 1000 reports 32
hours let's say
engineer one makes about 25 bucks an
hour it's a lot of money and time wasted
so we wanted to eliminate eliminate all
that
however due to how strict our procedures
are their methods are
we have very strict regulations when it
comes
to writing the report itself so strict
that even minor
errors or deviations from our templates
often result in rejections uh this is
actually an example
of a report we generated with our
program
uh as you could say it looks just like a
regular word document which is great
because that's what we were aiming for
we wanted to pass through our
documentation system
without any kickback and we could not do
that with html
or pdf so we had to rely heavily on the
word format
we did manage to get about two reports
into our documentation system
without the approvers themselves
noticing that the
this was our generated program
we do have certain regulations we had to
follow for example
all our reports are required to have a
cover page and that in that cover page
we are required to have a title
um the location of the document the
author's name
and the date it was generated in our
headers we were required to have our
logo
uh the test being the test study the
title
the number the revisions and the
pagination like all this is really hard
to do with word
and we had very very many setbacks with
this
moving towards the body we do have
regulations on our headers
they must be numbered in sequential
order
and certain section must contain uh
specific content we also had regulations
with our table
all the headers should be highlighted in
gray for the view reviewer should
could see the difference between headers
and actual data
we also add regulations that came to our
stat methods this example of a process
capability
uh whenever we do histograms or process
capability studies we are
required to show the cpk anything below
1.3 you're supposed to
generate a rationale on why it's allowed
um just a quick walk through for our
lifecycle report so like i said before
it takes about
four days to generate report
and after we generate a report we send
it out for approvals from then it takes
about two weeks
to hear back from our approvers our
approvers are really busy they're
usually higher level engineers
so taking about three hours of the time
to review our
report is another money pit and if they
find anything
they're gonna reject it kick it back and
we have to redo the process we have to
spend about another two hours of their
own time and our time
to fix any issues and then the cycle
begins again you could see
after constant rejections how many hours
of the day
and how much time we waste with just
writing
a simple report these are
some kind of areas we usually find
people will be using the wrong kind of
template for example someone used
a revge version of the template of the
newest
rev h this is very common since our
engineers like to
get previous approved reports and modify
them for their studies
this is another example they often when
they revise
previous reports they don't verify
if they change all the product names or
if there's any contradicting statements
for example
we're talking about uh cathode body in
the purpose but in scope we're talking
about catheter tip
that's a contradiction that will get us
in trouble with the fda
uh we're also talking about 32 samples
but in the acceptance criteria we
have about 30. there's also inconsistent
with our lot numbers and our units
all right so some restrictions we faced
is our rigid system
we would had to follow our template to
the t
or else it will get rejected and we have
to lose more time making a report
the second one is we have to submit it
in a word document
using r with our markdown with word was
one of the biggest
hurdles for us a lot of the packages do
not work with
word output so we had to figure little
tricky ways to get around it
our overall goal for the project was one
let me get as much of
time possible it takes to generate a
report
to make it super simple that could be
done in one click
three was review the user's
input to make sure there's no
mathematical errors no chemical
errors or any stat errors
then finally our last goal was we want
to make this
program flexible as possible to be used
for a variety of tests
we did not want a one-trick pony report
i'm going to hand the mic over to my
partner anna santos who will be
reviewing the program and the program
features
thank you so
as you can see you have have cumbersome
it could be to
make b reports so what approach did we
do
to actually improve this
process so first we specified
the reference document within our yaml
header the
reference document would serve as the
backbone
of the rest of the documents that we are
going to generate
and within the styles of the headings
and the word document
what we did was to edit the headings for
example we wanted to edit the font
the color the size and the indention
that way
we could mimic how the text are supposed
to be shown within the specified
procedures within our document system we
also specify that word document of
course is what we wanted as an output
because this is
the only type of document that is
allowed within our document management
system
now as much as we wanted to standardize
the
report generation procedure we also
wanted to give our users the flexibility
to actually be able to customize their
reports in their own ways because each
engineer
does different types of testings and
this would require different types of
analysis
so for this one we require them to input
a
raw data spreadsheet which includes the
specifications of the testing that they
have
performed we also have text input
sections where we could capture
the details of the title of the testing
that was performed
and who is the author of the report also
to give them
a flexibility when it comes to analyzing
we let them
choose from a pool of options of what
types of plots
they are able to show and with that
i mentioned earlier that users are
required to
input a raw data spreadsheet now you're
going to ask what
are the typical things that are within
the raw data spreadsheet so this is an
example
of a tone down raw data spreadsheet
and within here the specifications of
the testing is shown
such as the title of the testing that
was performed what are the steps that
has been done in order to
follow the procedure of the testing and
in here we could see the values that
were gathered within the testing that
has been performed
and also the bounds on which or where in
the measured data should fall into
and within this raw data input what we
do is check the data for any types of
inconsistencies
let's say there's inconsistencies within
days we
we are trying to catch that early on
that way it doesn't get escalated into
a higher level problem we also look into
the errors within grammar and spelling
and also we look for
drastic outliers because we wanted this
to be a potential problem in the future
if it's just a little typographical
error
and also you know sometimes our
engineers are rushing their reports
furiously typing
and sometimes accidentally they hit the
caps lock on
and we don't want it to be shown in the
report because what we we wanted to show
is
something in title case as shown in the
photo below
so stringer is really helpful to do that
the function string to upper and string
to title helps us to be able to control
this user inputs
now the report generation procedures
using r and having it in a reproducible
manner was never easy
there's a lot of things that are hurdles
along the way
so the first one is that the word
document headers were a little bit
difficult to
edit especially if you wanted the text
to appear dynamically
as the users input them and there's also
hurdles within
actually outputting the tables that are
following the specific
procedures that was outlined within our
documents
and also having users with different
backgrounds
different locations be able to access
this
change within the process of generating
the reports and also
lastly for users to further be able to
customize the reports that they're
trying to make
so how did we edit the word document
headers
based off the user's inputs so what we
did is we have a reference document
wherein we have keywords as you can see
the second photo has
quadruple x so we wanted to edit the
quadruple x
with the user input so packages
officer is really helpful for this
specifically the
headers replace alt text function what
it does is it looks for the keyword
and this keyword is replaced by the
input which for example is
capture tip diameter and then with this
this print function will save this in a
specific
path and this will be the reference
document that will be specified in the
ammo header
that way going forward all the documents
that will be
printed by the user will be as such
because we wanted
these tiles and revision levels to
appear
in the actual output so now
i specified earlier there is specific
formatting that has to be followed when
it comes to the tables that we're trying
to generate
and officer and flex table was really
useful
for such because we were able to make
beautiful tables and
actually output it in word and uh
pandock is definitely essential for
having this done
because it gives us a success to be able
to output it in word
and another feature that we like the
most with officer and select stable is
the style function where we could add a
conditional statement so within the
conditional statement
what we do is met the measured data
which in this case
is tip diameter we look if it is below
the lower
specification limit or above the upper
specification limit and if it does
then we wanted to highlight it because
this is probably a potential
type of concern that we wanted to
address early on so what we do is we
change the text of the color in red and
also italicize the text that way it
catches
the user's attention and then
going forward we wanted people within
the company with different backgrounds
different skill sets and different
locations to be able to access
this type of methodology so with that we
decided to leverage
the johnson johnson shiny server and
within that we deploy the shiny app that
has this
our markdown wrapped and um
with this it allowed for users to access
it within a web link put their inputs
and once they hit generate report
they could automatically have the report
properly formatted within their
downloads folder
also we were able to add more features
for
further customizations of the plots that
the users want to
actually generate so for example here
if the user uploads the raw data
spreadsheet
the column headers within the raw data
spreadsheet is red
and once this is read the drop down
menus for the scour plot
x-axis and scatter plot y-axis is
automatically updated with the column
headers
why do we want this is it's because like
the raw data spreadsheet column headers
could be edited by the users
and we want them to be comfortable as
possible and
easy for them to be able to generate
these plots
this is an example of a plot that was
generated by the user
now we showed you a little snippets of
how
the report looks like by going over a
few of our methodology
now that's a nice thing on the cake we
want to show you an example output keep
in mind that these
are not actual data and it's only used
for demonstration
purposes only so that is the
title page with the title and the author
name
we have the sections with the subsequent
parts of the sections properly indented
we have tables we have the table for
equipment we have procedures that are
shown sequentially
we have the failure highlighted in red
within the raw data table
then we have more observations as you
can see
and then further down the document we
have scatter plots
we have box plots with the failure
highlighted in red as shown as the
outlier we have normality plots
we have capability histograms and the
table below
that shows capability measurements that
were
also calculated and also below we could
see for example the recommendation
and this is the subsequent paragraph
that is in the introduction
of the section is properly indented and
then the actual
recommendation is further intended so
these are the little things that we
made sure is also captured
now what do we want you to take away
from this presentation
you may think that the methodology shown
might not be as complex
but the key idea here that we learned
along the way is we wanted to challenge
all of you we wanted to challenge each
one of you
as you go back home through your
individual organizations like we want
you to promote the idea of reproducible
data analysis
of with your individual organizations
because
along the way we've seen how it is
important within a company we wanted you
to
be able to eliminate documentation
errors and
when you once you do that you could
actually
be be able to focus on higher level
issues also this is just one application
of reproducible data analysis and we
know that under
different job functions you could also
implement such methodology
and lastly once you are able to
successfully deploy
such i think that you could eliminate
bottlenecks within your own systems and
for us gathered here today
i think if we free up some time within
our own day-to-day work functions
we could write more scripts we could
deploy more applications and i think
that is a win-win situation for all of
us it's an investment that we're making
for further down the line lastly we
would like to thank the following people
for their time and assistance
for this project thank you and
yeah thank you
[Applause]
all right we have uh three minutes for
questions here so let's tackle a few of
these
real quick if i can pull them up um have
you tried out the gt package for
custom tables have you heard of that
package
is this relatively new i don't think
it's on cran yet but it is a new package
that's uh
out for creating custom tables no no
we will check it out yeah yeah um second
question is
how much iteration has this project
required that is
are reporting requirements subject to
change
yes um it's not as often
as a new as you think i think
every year to half a year we get a new
update in documents
the changes are minor so we just have to
change
the um code slightly to
fit the new template fantastic all right
um how were the process control charts
produced
custom package do you know um
for the capability histogram the library
the package ggqc was used and then
[Music]
the process capability measures is
coming from another package
that i'm trying to think about
capability tools
yeah i mean whoever asked that question
if you
connect with me i could get back to you
sorry about that
one last question here once you put the
report in word
how do you handle changes to the
document how do you incorporate
feedback edits to the word doc back into
our markdown
sorry the previous question is just
remember the package the
the package used to calculate the
process capability measures is qcc
qcc okay so last question here real
quick uh once you put the report in word
how do you handle changes to the
document
and then they have a second question how
do you incorporate feedback edits to the
word doc
back into markdown so
so if they're asking about the feedback
of the approvers so basically the
approvers would would put a note within
the document management system and the
since the output is in word it gives the
flexibility for
the actual author to be able to edit it
but um the users don't have
access to the our markdown file itself
it's only the programmers to add access
if that answers the question
they do have the capability of emailing
us and we could make those modifications
to fit
the overall report better because what
we also wanted to control
is users trying to favor
themselves in the creation of the
reports that's why we still wanted that
control
got it all right well thank you let's
give him a hand
thank you
you